ganamos tres años en el poder y
polémicas que lo han perseguido
prácticamente desde el inicio de su
mandato el conservador Alejandro
giamatei ganó las elecciones de agosto
de 2019 y juramentó como presidente el
15 de enero de 2020 cargado de
esperanzas para los guatemaltecos somos
capaces de superar la desnutrición de
superar
la
inseguridad juntos podemos lograr una
Guatemala en donde podamos vivir en paz
en progreso con desarrollo y con
justicia clamamos Guatemala entre sus
principales promesas acabar con la
migración de guatemaltecos a Estados
Unidos la pobreza y con la corrupción
pero con el paso del tiempo pocas o
ningunas se han materializado en
noviembre de 2020 miles de manifestantes
salieron a las calles del país para
expresar su descontento con el
presupuesto de 2021 al que acusaron de
no combatir la pobreza y fomentar la
desigualdad que este presupuesto
incluirá mecanismos de transparencia y
rendición de cuentas Pero quizás el tema
más polémico de su mandato ha sido la
corrupción Y es que desde que asumió el
cargo tanto organizaciones
anticorrupción como la comunidad
internacional lo han acusado de
perseguir a los que la combaten en lugar
de a los corruptos
cerca de 30 jueces como la antigua
fiscal anticorrupción Virginia la Parra
se han visto forzados a huir del país
por cargos elegales en su contra
organismos anticorrupción como el de
Naciones Unidas y sus directores a
también han corrido la misma suerte al
igual que periodistas como José Rubén
Zamora crítico con el gobierno y
condenado a seis años de prisión por
supuesto lavado de dinero además en su
línea conservadora su administración
aumentó las penas de prisión por abortar
y prohibió el matrimonio homosexual
según organismos como Naciones Unidas el
país vive un retroceso democrático desde
2019 justo cuando guía ganó la
presidencia